and a matter of record that about 30 40
years ago or maybe even earlier than
that the liberal establishment became
co-opted by the same Financial interests
that have traditionally been associated
with right-wing politics if you look at
the conditions that led to the war in
Iraq and the kind of relationships and
the kind of re restructuring that took
place in that country and the
catastrophe that happened around that
war that was Cheney and Bush and now
look at what's happening elsewhere and
there are sort of I would say comparable
conversations that could take place and
it's pretty clear where like their sort
of Clinton Foundation gets money from
and the way that they advocate for
particular things so what I feel like is
and is that the solution will not come
from within that system I don't want to
Glory it by reveling in the differences
thank you
what was the moment that you got sort of
into this the politics side of this
thing I know it's not you're not really
political in a way but you clearly are
talking about politics but was that I
mean you're an actor in a comic like was
that kind of always in you or was there
like a moment that had happened did
kovid kind of escalate it that's a comic
that's a type of a job isn't it like a
like a comedian actually for me is a
sort of beyond the job that's a religion
yeah that's a purpose it's a perspective
actor is a type of a job for me uh the
the the or My World Views is part of my
condition is part of where I come from
it's part of what I believe in and the
becoming an actor that's just simply
just opportunism I was doing stand-up
comedy I got jobs on the TV as a result
of that I then got off of movies all of
these things oh these are all
interesting exciting things and by God
were they exciting and for for a while
but my actual what would we be like if
it look I sometimes like this if it
didn't exist would I invent it if it
didn't like you know if there was no
such thing as a movie industry would I
go why don't we spend like 100 million
dollars telling this story and what
we'll do is we'll get to trailers at
four o'clock in the morning I'll stay in
there most of the time then I'll pop out
for a bit and like do some a little bit
of acting no what I want to do is
communicate truthfully and connect
people if anything it's like a kind of
secular and inclusive evangelism that's
deeply devout and accepting of the
different ways that people might find
God so that each of us are going to have
our own journey to God that doesn't mean
that people might not be part of a a
religious community or indeed a global
Faith but that if we do not have a
connection to something that I would
call sublime or Divine that we are
likely to become lost in materialism
individualism nihilism and progressivism
and by progressivism I don't mean
culture progressivism the idea that
human beings are on this journey to
better and better stuff and that doesn't
seem to be happening other than I would
say through the false markers of
medicine technology and although they
are marvelous great Miracles is that
what you're up to more than anything
else that we're just like in this lack
of truth right now and even to bring it
back to the real-time moment like you
were trying to say something true in a
cultural world where nothing is true
right like you do your show every day
you talk about politics and it's like a
lot of it is just debunking
right like the people that just shovel
all day long yes that's what
that is what I'm trying to do I'm trying
to
um what I feel like mate is that I'm
limited in my understanding of most
things in fact the sum total of all
human knowledge is negligible compared
to their vast limitlessness of all
potential realities so there has to be a
kind of blunt pregnant pragmatism to the
way that we organize culture and society
and the only reference that that I can
access is how did we evolve did we
evolve to living giant communities I can
see that there are ways where living
like having broad alliances would be
hugely beneficial I can see that there
are ways where the Miracles of
technology and medicine and science are
hugely hugely applicable obviously of
course I live in the world but it seems
that there is an invisible ideology that
doesn't declare and state itself
explicitly and all of their even
apparent cultural arguments happen take
place within its framework and what I
would call it is commodification
consumerism late capitalism corporatism
Global corporatism neoliberalism that
this ideology isn't being openly
discussed and it's at its nadir it's
dying it's already dead it died in 2008
and now we've got something bizarre and
monstrous so we have like a Frankenstein
trying to keep it together or something
while they were rearranging chairs on
the Titanic as they're sinking something
like that yes that's what I feel like
yes that's what I feel like and I feel
like if it is not
succinctly and explicitly addressed
we're going to experience new types of
authoritarianism that frame themselves
in albeit apparently novel ways that
benefit hugely from arguing about the
sort of stuff like even you know the
stuff about like the public schools or
whatever when plainly like that if you
said I want to raise my kids in this way
I'd go oh okay let me know what I know
and I would assume that you would be the
same with me like who cares like as long
as it's not you know we'll know what a
sort of abuse there seem to be some
Universal ideas that we understand when
you're when you're traveling do you see
places that it's working better than
other places I mean now you've been a
couple days in Florida but you were just
in Cali where it's obviously way
different I did a stand-up show in
Clearwater yeah and I really liked it
and what I do recognize yes and I do
recognize that there's a sort of a deep
sense of sort of like Pride here and
that obviously somewhat due to the
stance that Florida took during the
lockdown the
anti-orthoritarianism is being expressed
you know like that the governor is the
anti-government figure in in your state
but uh and and you know why not I'm not
pessimistic about human beings generally
speaking but like I would always just
look at where is the funding coming from
what's the ultimate intention what kind
of alliances I've just ask the same
questions they would ask of anybody is
it as Democratic as possible and I'm
like you know and the it's better than I
would always reject from both sides as
we've said that's what I was sort of
rejecting on the tele program the other
day and I'm I don't know run the
scientists through all I know he could
be Jesus but like you know like sort of
like I'm pretty sure he's 19. but maybe
I can get you guys to sit down for
coffee yeah God absolutely you know I'd
like that I'd like that I what I do
accept is that
what that Dave is that I I feel that we
want the maximum amount of authority in
our own lives Max like personal
Authority and autonomy excuse me and the
maximum amount of democracy and like I
told you at the beginning of this
conversation I don't really like
controversy and I don't think that any
of that stuff's even particularly
complicated I'm just sort of inviting
people that identify on the right to be
as Discerning as I would invite people
that identify on the left to be like who
are we definitely operating on behalf of
Ordinary People totally inclusive
non-judgmental completely loving not
secretly operated on behalf of economic
interests in some you know is one of
those directions easier than the other
like right now obviously people are on
the right dig here and that's I think
probably a little weird for you in some
respects right like people that maybe a
couple years ago you thought ah these
weren't yeah my people but they're
that's what I found you know I was a
lefty my whole life and then suddenly I
started saying a few things about
Freedom kind of what you're preaching
here in a probably more simplistic way
the next thing I knew all these people
that that I thought were the bad guys
were like hey you want to have dinner
let's see what's what
but what we'll say I like how you switch
mugs like like that I don't know what
was in there I have no idea what's in
there I know so it's gone from Blue to
Red yeah
huh yeah
um because in a way it doesn't matter
they're both basically the same right
wow
um but because
there's still statistics on where the
funding comes from on the number of
people in Congress that own stocks and
chairs in like energy companies or the
military industrial complex it's just
basically the same it's just basically
the same so that's just sort of my
position certainly I've found that
people
uh like that I identify as being sort of
conservative or republican or whatever
have been very open to this conversation
and look I it's clear to me
and a matter of record that about 30 40
years ago or maybe even earlier than
that the liberal establishment became
co-opted by the same Financial interests
that have traditionally been associated
with right-wing politics if you look at
the conditions that led to the war in
Iraq and the kind of relationships and
the kind of re restructuring that took
place in that country and the
catastrophe that happened around that
war that was Cheney and Bush and now
look at what's happening elsewhere and
there are sort of I would say comparable
conversations that could take place and
it's pretty clear where like their sort
of Clinton Foundation gets money from
and the way that they advocate for
particular things so what I feel like is
and is that the solution will not come
from within that system I don't want to
Glory it by reveling in the differences
because actually where I am from is a
normal modest blue-collar working class
background in Essex England and when I
see people demonized on the basis of
their class or their culture whether
they are in the dominant cultural group
sexually or racially or culturally or a
smaller a cultural group you know by
those markers if economically we are
attacking people if we're attacking a
class that is economically dispossessed
then I feel like oh I see what's
happening now I see what's happening I
see why people are angry I see why
people feel that they're being spoken
down to they are being spoken down to
and I suppose
Dave that that's the thing that I felt
wasn't being addressed and isn't being
addressed that the blame is being put on
people that aren't empowered and also
that there's an escalation of you know
the the the the kind of accusations
around uh God what do I want to say
perjuring people's beliefs oh those
people are just racist those people are
just this or just that and I I'm
actually generally quite optimistic
about people and think that people will
get along if you leave them alone and if
you don't impecuniate them and
impoverish them if you're looking for
more uncensored opinions from today's
thought leaders check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a wide variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification Bell